marcus coming off his start against the
yankees as last time out they went just
five innings his previous start against
the phillies went only three so looking
for a little more length this afternoon
with the mitts facing a doubleheader
today in a day game tomorrow two out of
nobody on now brian reynolds the
all-star center fielder he went over
four last night
and he gets this one on the air to right
center pretty well hit back goes nimman
to the warning track back at the wall
leaping and
he made the catch oh wow
brandon nemo timing it perfectly and
taking a whole run away from brian
reynolds
a spectacular play by nimmo to end the
top of the first leaps at the wall
reaches over the fence and just robbed
brian reynolds
of a home run one of the best catches
you'll ever see
and a well-deserved standing o for the
center fielder of the mets go to the
bottom of the first pirates nothing the
mets are coming to back tyler anderson
in 16 games is 4-8 with a 4-3-9 92 and a
third innings pitch 24 walks and 78
strikeouts the mets have runners at the
corners with one out that's lined over
short basement for pillar and that'll
bring in the first run of the game
nemo comes in to score pilar with the
rbi single and it's one nothing new york
these bench mobsters
they they just keep coming through for
the mets
kevin pillar gets a fastball up tried to
come in on him similar to the one on
pete but pilar was able to get his hands
to the baseball get enough barrel on it
to
send it over shortstop
actually a little cutter coming in on
him
great job there by pallarda to pull the
hands in
sneak this thing over the shortstop
tucker's head
and just look at that that last second
he gets the hands out in front and then
able to pull them almost across his body
and get the get that bat head to the
ball just enough john nagowski the
legend continues three for four with a
walk last night so as a pirate in four
games 10 hits in 16 at bats and three
walks
and dagowski did it go he did strike
three
first base on fire eric bakkers with the
call and that's the second strikeout for
strowman
no hesitation on that one from the
umpire eric and
looks like he did go around good call
there
strike three for marcus and as we say
he's starting to get more strikeouts and
less ground balls he gets a ground ball
and then a k there's wilmar defoe the
former national and defoe flicks one to
shallow left outlander in smith and
smith makes the cash side retire six up
and six down for marcus strowman one
nothing marcus strowman getting some
ground outs here in the third two up two
down to bring up the pitcher tyler
anderson one two coming and he struck
him out and strowman's gone perfectly
through the pirates
the first time through the order nine up
and nine down for strowman on just 29
pitches one nothing minutes going to the
bottom of the third anderson in the
sixth season nine of 13 first pitch
strikes that's pretty
there you good
just a lazy fly ball out to right nice
sequence of pitching right there and a
one two three inning for tyler anderson
so the two all-stars getting base hits
against strowman here in the fourth and
the pirates are set up with first and
third and one out long look in for
strowman now the pitch
check swing and a miss strike three
third base umpire dan i estonia is the
one who has rung up gamel who has some
words with the home plate umpire andy
fletcher camel strikes out it's a second
out of the inning for marcus strowman
who's now fan four in this game but now
it's down to uh john nagowski with two
outs three one count strowman now with a
pitch
ground ball and fair past the third
baseman vr the big nagowski has tied it
headed around third reynolds he will
scores the ball kicks away from smith
no go
john nagowski the legend continues
it is 2-1 pittsburgh as he rips a double
into the left-field corner
this is an amazing story it really is an
amazing story i mean he knows how to hit
for whatever reason he never got it
going this year when he was with the
cardinals and maybe because he didn't
get consistent at bats but
man not only is he getting consistent at
bats but what a great approach
consistently
just in there grinding and getting into
hitters counts and
3-1 gets a pitch in turns on it right
inside the line got down in that corner
dominic smith had some trouble but my
goodness and now one more defoe and
nagowski at second and two out it's the
strowman manipulating the ball to the
grip he wants and he strikes out defoe
got him with a cutter to end the inning
five strikeouts for storming but the
pirates lead two to one going to the
bottom of the fourth inning of the seven
into game one
vr gets one to deep left field back near
the wall and it's out of here
jonathan vr has struck again
two home runs last night and a towering
blast to get the minutes even today
number nine for vr and it's two to two
in the fourth
the mets continue to get contributions
from guys that
they weren't expecting i think at the
beginning of the year and vr
like you said coming off the two home
runs last night
just a huge home run in a seven inning
game to get them back in this thing
gets a cutter should have been in wanted
it to be in
able to get the barrel to it and just
drives this thing elevates it out of the
ballpark that is as high a home run i
think as we've seen this year now tyler
anderson comes to the plate
what why would you bunt
hit it out
wow
tyler anderson just swatted a home run
unbelievable
oh that was awesome maybe he was just
deaking him trying to bring the infield
in
second home run in his career
and he gives the pirates the lead
oh that was awesome
99.6 miles per hour off the bat look at
this this is a cutter that didn't cut
just kind of barrel spun up there and
dropped the barrel down on the baseball
second career home run and it's his
first since july the 9th
2016. now the pirates are now leading
3-2 trevor may takes over for new york
in this sixth inning brian reynolds
a little cushion here
out to the wall and gone brian reynolds
he had one taken away before
redemption a two-run home run for the
all-star
he's got it figured out
hit it a little bit higher a little bit
farther than you did in the first inning
and they can't get there
look at that 99 miles an hour off the
bat
390 feet he pulled this one a little bit
more than he did in the first hand it
looked like a split that stayed up or
change up that stayed up up and out over
the middle of the plate brian reynolds
put a good swing on it hit that ball
hard here's keep ryan hayes last inning
he walked to start
get through there
and because he gets into second base he
will score he's trying for two he's in
there with a double give him a run
batted in and the pirates lead it six to
two well looks like the mets want to
review this the mets aren't challenging
this did hayes for a split second lose
contact with the bag i didn't see
anything there that would the umpires
rule it as stands unless you can really
really really see it
well that's what it's supposed to be
right sure indisputable evidence pirates
do have a six to two lead they've out
hit the mets nine to seven pirates going
to rich rodriguez right here to try and
close out the win it's not a save
situation but going to him the guy's
been spectacular all year
and he takes care of nemo
a one two three seventh inning for
richard rodriguez
and the pirates have one in the bank in
this doubleheader